thank you the great director Frank Capra
said there are three universal languages
music mathematics and the one we honor
tonight the universal language of film
regardless of its country of origin or
of the dialect of its words a great film
conveys a story that speaks to the one
condition we all share the human
condition here are the nominees for Best
Foreign Language Film from Gmail a
fantastic woman directed by Steve Austin
Livia
the neverland the insult directed by zio
Joe Eddie from NASA Lovelace directed by
armed raids the agency from Hungary on
body and soul
directed by indica and yearly from
Sweden the square directed by women
Estlin and the Oscar goes to a fantastic
and second nomination for Chile
[Applause]
thank you so much this is an amazing
gift thank you to the Academy I want to
well thank my dear friends and producers
who alum the awesome part of Lorraine I
want to thank the cast of the film
especially the brilliant actor Francisco
Reyes and the inspiration for this movie
vanilla Vega this film was made by a lot
of friends an artist I share this with
all of you tonight I want to thank Aaron
Brown and Sophie Dolan everyone from
Sony classics Tom Barnard Michael Barker
participant media September Rossini
completes and films and my wife Virginia
I love you forever thank you so so much
[Applause]